inflation in america is beginning to
bite now the highest it's been in 40
years prices rising 8.6
over the year through may and it isn't
just about numbers it's about sacrifice
it's rough i mean this everything is so
high
yeah it's taking all your money and then
you just have to sit down and eat less
it means americans paychecks simply
don't go as far as they used to flying
costs 37 percent more rent that's up
almost 7 percent and food is across the
board more expensive the price of
chicken up 5 percent in a year you might
find
chicken in one price for the same weight
and then go back and it's different
higher
a little bit higher the biggest increase
by far
gas it is up by almost 50 percent in
just a year according to gas buddy
that's a website that tracks costs the
average gallon of gas in the us is five
dollars the highest it has ever been
there are numerous reasons for the
rising prices a spike in food and energy
costs resulting from russia's invasion
of ukraine is one putin's price hike is
hitting america hard
but other prices are rising because of
the ongoing supply chain issues
triggered by the covid pandemic there's
too much demand not enough supply and a
shortage of transportation capacity
president joe biden is also blaming
company consolidation for many of the
increases there are nine
nine major ocean line shipping companies
that ship from asia to the united states
nine
they form three consortium
these companies have raised their prices
by as much as one thousand percent
congress is poised to pass a bill that
would give u.s regulators more power
over the shipping companies but that
likely won't have an immediate impact
and next week the federal reserve is
poised to raise interest rates again
meaning debt will be that much more
expensive for americans and when
interest rates keep rising people feel
well credit is less easy to access it's
harder to buy a home that's also you
know a negative but
these are the sorts of things that have
to happen as you say the central bank
needs to take action it is taking action
in attempt to stabilize the u.s economy
with americans paying a heavy price
patty culhane al jazeera washington